okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is one of a probably for
design review meetings just today
preparing for the new version of Wolfram
language and this one is about database
integration so so all of these things I
mean in the production version there
won't be any loading to be done correct
yes okay all right so let's take a look
at this creature here so this is
database connection why is that of a
noun
rather than a I mean in other words is
this it because right now like if you
just do data base connection that
doesn't do anything so you're not Clark
okay fine so that's that okay so then
then database inspect actually does
something yes and that what is that ID
it's an internal ID that is being used
to identify connection uniquely internal
by whom by us yeah by the system by our
system okay if it's gonna be an ID I
think it should be capital i capital B
not is that like a
is that like a WS TP connection ID or
what is it it's not a UUID no it's a
national given action
it's basically so that the next time
you're using basically same credential
you're always getting the same ID it's
calculated by doing an ash of the
payload of your connection credentials
okay but so what what is that like
elsewhere in the system and should it be
in UUID format for example this is a
hash so that's why it's not just an EU
UID because we were using that to you
know to compute so this thing is
computable from a connection
expression we get it I get it I
understand it's a hash but the hash I'm
just asking where else in the system do
we have do we expose such a thing why is
this exposed to the user it can be it
can be yes I mean we can just have a
method here that is the reason is that
if you have like two connection with the
very same credential but for some either
you want to use two of them since we are
out of managing them you will need to
provide a different ID so that that
could be documented but otherwise you
know we're basically if you're given
just a credential we are computing an
idea is always going to be the same
maybe we should call it connection hash
or something like that or connection at
least it should be called connection ID
not just ID okay yeah and I think for
now we can safely hide this information
in the in in the output boxes because
it's not it's only used internally by us
okay
of course if you were connecting to
something like Postgres you would have
seen that something difference in our
password stuff like this there is a
specification that is an authorization
and otherwise not so URL specification
or even season tonight Postgres like a
URL and then a connection or not okay
let's open that but it seems to me here
when you say back-end
shouldn't that be database type or
something it can but it's just a
widespread term for designating what
kind of database is being used so we're
just using the standard term well I
don't know it seems like if somebody
sees you know it depends what the
population is that's reading this I
would've thought database type there's a
better name for that maybe engine
also it's fine I mean technically
they're all the same type of database
they're more like dialects okay fine
so database engine then that the right
name that will do okay and then name is
like database name because of the
necessarily the name of the database
because one has killed more than one
database right that is the name of the
database in SQL is basically the file
you know if you were connecting to boss
Chris you would have said something like
engine goes to Bosphorus and then name
goes to that AB is named and there is
the host the username alright so there's
some additional things that can appear
here let me get an inventory of
everything that can appear there okay I
just I'm noticing it I'm pointing it out
what will move past this in just a
second okay um there are colons missing
here right and where it says connection
SQLite what does that even mean I mean
that's identifying this particular
connection but why is it calling it
askew like that did you get what I'm
asking
yeah it's just a disease it's briefly
designate that same connection though
the designation leading rescue light
here and it should be consistent we're
making sense so what you want to do but
if you can't say connection : this up
here and then
I mean what this thing here is
essentially a summary of this thing here
right yes right so make sure they're
consistent that's what I'm saying
yes yeah okay okay so this segue to
schema tables per n3 what does that mean
what what what else would there be other
than tables there could also later be
other database things like constraints
all right then
then tables is a heading like schema is
and it seems to me like it should say
you know what this should say is
something more like I don't know why
that doesn't just say tables unless you
want an outer layer but it says schema
so to speak right well the schema is
more than just tables so it's more like
higher-level thing and then there should
be a subcategory there that is also gray
like that not schema is tables because
schema isn't tables yeah so I mean if if
that wants to say tables paren in gray
three total for example and then you
open it up
that would be reasonable enough make
sense yeah I think the reason we did it
this way right now is that we only now
have a single one and we wanted to skip
one level of indirection here okay well
I don't think you should because I think
you should make it more you know you
should build for for what we're doing in
the future yeah okay next comment um
these icons are really ugly if I might
say so
can we get designed to deal with them
like yeah there are a lot of information
that for example are not that we're all
a displaying tables but there are
database level information we will like
to show you so what why don't you guys
try and expect that and then try and
meet on your own with the graphic design
folk okay and I'm also saying these
icons here really ugly can we please fix
those sure sure that does it just yeah
something that we made all the time
I made out by us who's andreas project
managing here right yes I am okay so can
you make sure that these get that these
guys have a session with graphic design
and try and work on those yes you did it
okay all right so why is database
inspect returning a thing that is a
schema this doesn't say schema this oh
this says SQL database object okay fair
enough I get it
that's reasonable enough okay entities
store this is exciting
why is it taking so long how big is this
database
hi Matt oh my god add some such amazing
boxes for taste what can you know about
that information yeah no that's that's
that's I mean it should show but that's
the second argument of but it's it would
be really important that you can you
check that and see what the version of
entity framework is to publish
information like this very much because
maybe you have a build that hasn't
picked up all the latest changes that
Tony introduced to plug in you know
delegating of like that yeah so Tony can
you tell if this contains our changes no
it does not contain them okay so how do
I get the version that does ok Tony are
you there yes
so can I just say Packard updated this
no I maybe you can send sense you in the
pocket that's that that's the latest
from master just zip the master version
ah how do I install it I don't know how
to install it
no I I can tell you how to install it
but if you can sensed you in a zipped
version of master then then we can make
it work
push it on again because we don't want
to push it for everyone
in the meantime Stephen could you just
check the version number of the build
you're using the version number yeah but
September 11 is three days old are you
sure you're using the latest thing that
Roger installed which thing I'm using
the master branch build yeah it's our
youth into Mathematica build instead of
that's the problem
yeah this this Mathematica build is
probably what we want
well Roger should have been still wolf
from desktop that's what I normally use
yeah I think I think on the phone please
notice the last two numbers of the
mathematical version that's the build
that okay this is a September 12th one
so I can use that instead you don't have
okay which which what do I look number
in please don't type in our ears what
which which version what should I be
looking for here
a virtual number maybe it's not for no
ado system information small yes this
information is course for okay is this
the correct version um yeah it looks
like looks like one I'll just double
check yeah it ends with 24 so it should
be the right 6 3 o 24 yes
that's so do we still need roger I
thinking but ok reduce you ok which
version did these guys these guys needed
me to install a version what was the
version that they needed me to install
it was Mathematica the so wasn't well
from desktop because that's what we
should be installing I know I understand
nobody told me that
okay alright okay so that was a screw-up
I did tell say that ok so that was but
that shouldn't that shouldn't happen
again but okay all right fine enough
said
okay thanks yep
ok let's restart this
now we are doing this incredibly long
grind here presumably yeah so the very
next thing I'm going to do steering is
to are really getting to dig inside and
on to optimize this thing okay so that
it will take less time but so okay so
database connection right that's just a
static representation of the database
connection without having activated it
right yeah really really timely yeah so
the reason why we were not really
putting too much resources so far into
this was that it's only one time
operation I understand I understand but
we need to get that salt because that's
ridiculously long right now yeah
absolutely
okay so what is that entity thing there
what does that mean that I mean that's a
placeholder that I did in 20 seconds
because I want to have something
colorful okay okay all right okay okay
so I just wanted to like the bold thing
is the canonical property the one that
constructs the canonical name in in SQL
is the is the primary and things with
the arrows and the underline our
relations and we'll get to that then
there is another point that you will see
if you do the other anti stores is you
can have some some properties can be
italic and that means that they are
computed rather than stored in the
database so if you look at the other
ones at the other constructors France in
store which which things here well just
register this in the meantime so until
you register for that entity store okay
so that will register hold on hold on
hold on let me understand this so these
are types again this needs some graphic
design help because the way this is
working is kind of yucky I mean the
functionality is quite beautiful it
looks Kentucky makes sense yeah sure um
okay so if I say then if I'm just just
four mice for my sake if I then say
entity list nation then those are the
unformatted entities of Nations found in
that period right there's a whole kind
of warranties guess about meat boxes and
typesetting of this stuff but later give
me a preview here because I mean go
ahead that the way these things have
been designed for for entries that are
backed by alpha is that there is a
prefetch then there is a cache and then
basically the mate box is to check that
the entities really exist and the cache
is rather long-lived and so in general
you end up doing it something that is a
local operation now if you were to
actually every time you try to format
one entity call the database and say hey
is this entity valid and what are its
labels then it would take forever I mean
even now it's kind of slow if you look
at the difference between when you have
like 20 entities the main boxes take
about 3 seconds and the main point is
validating that that entity really
exists is that correct yeah and that's a
concept that's kind of imbalance for try
why don't we have another format that
isn't quite as bright and yellow and
orange bordered that means this is a
some kind of foreign entity you know a
user-defined entity that will format
this way whether or not so long as it's
a registered entity type it will format
that way whether or not the entity only
to exist yeah because I mean for for our
ends is kind of crazy to perform imagine
the only remark is here is that that
will be perfect solution but it will not
be able to do any differentiating based
on the entity properties will be generic
thing but that's what I'm saying I'm
saying I'm saying what this would do is
it would have something which is not as
bright and orange bordered as this
right it will be perhaps something with
yellow with out with a different kind of
border like a gray border okay and so
long as nation is a validated entity
type it would format that way am i
making sense yeah definitely oh wait a
second wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait where do we get the common name
from entity type as a label property
then this is used otherwise it falls
back to the canonical name okay well
fine but that's fine that's fine I mean
again we need formatting for this um
let's let's have a block of either this
meeting or a subsequent meeting where we
get the design folk in here Andrea can
you please make a note that is another
thing that needs design yes I am making
else for the design Thanks okay all
right so entities store person commerce
schema what does that mean that means
Megan entities store the schema could
have hundreds of types we are on
electing one remind me how this works
with the with it with the operation of
entity store so what is the first
argument normally it's an association
okay so why is this here we got echo
here but why is this oh I see represents
entry store for entities of type quotes
type okay by the way I presumably don't
need the braces here correct so far you
know but I will relax that okay all
right so the whole point is here that
the second argument of entities store is
the backing object yes ah
what does that
argument and restore mean with just a
type there without payload in the
documentation
the most cases are in memory so they are
placed in the same into the same
argument no no that I'm saying entities
store of type Tony what is that it's an
empty type an empty store again I read
and now I finally read it ok types count
what does that mean
what does types can't mean
the total number of types that this
store contains
what's that but are those properties yes
when the properties bridge type so this
should say types I mean that the types
is the top level of this but what this
is then listing is a person and then
it's listing with properties of that
person yeah I mean the weather when it's
closed then those are the types when
it's open type so so how does this
normally work for an entity store
so normally its type
types here right Tony yes what does it
do if there are multiple types if
multiple types and you get a shorter
summary so let's say I know this here
um and I add to that a
in addition to this I have a t-prime
I think you are anything sir like the
wrong model
you need to close the first Association
yeah and then you then
yeah that's list okay
I see okay so that's what that looks
like so that's a different format from
the one that you're using down here yeah
because I figured that I mean one of the
first databases that I was testing it
like over ten tables and yeah I know I
don't think it's gonna work so I suspect
this one needs to be changed in fact yes
yes I agree that could be updated to the
better database
we're actually formatting okay fine um
let's see whether okay we're gonna get
hung up on this here okay but I think
I'll okay I think I understand this so
let's let's go ahead and um this needs
significant design here but let's keep
going here okay so this what is this
doing this is remaining
I mean suppose we don't like the
lowercase person we want more Wolfram e
thing we have okay you can do that it's
just a listing and you can do it at the
property level how do I do it properly
level one blade and consistent with
Tony's way of doing entity store correct
Tony yes okay
you
okay then I'm can compute it property
right yes and now if you if you should
evaluate that you will see that in that
case it becomes italic and in which you
is something that will be very important
if one day we try to writes that
database you cannot write ratio so that
has to be I understand
okay so there that says okay property
extractor this cool
be nice if that had dumb syntax coloring
that flowed through but that's a
separate problem okay
and then you can even computed types
well that's wrong females should have
sex half but other than that okay but
what is this now well the entity class
so out of person you're making two
different types one is type males and at
this point they don't work like entity
classes they work like drone types so
class is an implicit entity selector
with the setting male is M is that
correct yeah that is picking from person
Oh bitchin generous can be anything
let's say if you have something that
you're using a lot this case mates and
female yeah you can basically register a
shortcut for it right and it's that
shortcut being that short guys being
cashed inside our system but somehow in
the that's a definition there is sent
out in the compiled SQL code that yeah
yeah basically what happens is that it's
like you're you're in lining the
definition in the query
okay so anyway this is stuff that okay
so that would be
that is an entity type right so this is
exactly what I would expect
yes those first three valiant illegality
around just what it's already in the
system nothing new here so now for the
first time here is in a relation like so
person friend is something that we also
generate from a foreign key so person as
a foreign key to itself that's a friend
it also has enemy so where is this
friend I'm sorry where is that it's that
in the entity store here somewhere
yeah the one that you registered though
if you go way up person friend person
friend persuade me so he out of the
foreign key in this case since it's to
itself you also get the reverse relation
oh yeah hold on so what is this to type
so this is a foreign key that person has
to itself and then use it use it to
generate something like I don't know
like father mother flying it like a tree
okay so this is the destination type of
the relation that could have been
another table but in this case we are
showing you know that we can go into
this relationship
look at scroll up this is not the anti
story you registered if you look at the
anti story you register you will see a
relation to nation and yeah so there is
that there is a so you see look at the
arrows the ones that have a direct arrow
means that they are foreign keys once
there have any error in the other
direction our reverse relations and they
they are substantially different so this
is a relation that goes what is why is
this property extractor what is that
okay let me explain
open transaction to start with
transaction transaction simple so each
transaction is a transaction no open the
transaction type lower yeah that one so
it's transact
has a foreign key to foreign keys one
school tool and the other is called from
two-person now those to generate to
directly relations to person when it's
called person to and the other scott
person from so these are the direct
relations and so basically this means
that these are entity valued for each
transaction there is a person to a
person from now this also generates the
reverse relation which is basically an
entity class that says for each person
what are the transactions and involved
in as tool and what are the transaction
and both - as from yeah I understand but
I'm still trying to understand this okay
so what exactly do so basically this
thing is the the bare minimum that is
needed to construct this relation so you
need you need in the table to point to a
type two point two and a condition which
has more or less the same syntax as a
joint condition but my mean so this
would be in our world this would be
entity class person - arrow ID is that
correct no in this case it would be
entry glass transaction well if you want
no I think that's purse I'm sorry and
Tikas person and then the ID goes to ID
goes to and then and then you would have
anti value of entity transaction one for
example now you need one entity
otherwise the font work and read
transaction one one is just okay it
comma to to Teo so this is the
reversed relation I don't understand I'm
trying to translate this association
it's something I can understand
I don't want this I was tested yeah yeah
okay what does this do wait that one
that you just wrote is just entity that
one sorry the one you just selected is
just entity all transaction no of person
sorry
yeah person right person comma and then
there you have entity value transaction
oh yeah I got it wrong what of the one
below just copy the one below I got
confused with the this yeah this thing
here yeah that's the correct one and I
don't understand I don't know standard
at all so if you evaluate the entity
value this basically have to evaluate in
place the entity value and then you get
the canonical name yeah I understand
what the point of that is I'm trying to
understand the translation okay let's go
in here that's it
that's what I'm trying to understand
yeah so that Association will tell you
that the the transaction so when you
when you have a transaction you have a
relation to a person and that tells you
how to construct the entity from that
what entity the entity for the
transaction the N type person that that
transaction has a property of so each
transaction has two properties of type
person one is the person two and one is
the person from those are constructed
from the foreign keys so you out of the
transaction you get the value for the
foreign key 2 and then you just stick it
in the second argument 20 and that's how
it's constructed I don't understand what
this Association that Association tells
you so basically it is the first
argument tells you the type you're going
to and the second argument is the same
ducks as a join condition I know but
it's also the same syntax as the
implicit entity correct are in play yeah
but it's it's not that it's a it's
because that could technically be an
entity function the condition it's not
okay but this is this is a more literal
form of the second argument to entity to
implicitly specify an entity is that
correct
is well no it always gives you the
actual name or the entities so because
it's not always an end even sometimes
it's an entity sometimes it's an entity
class it depends what kind of relation
you're following okay I hate these names
we can change it I mean this is okay so
first point is by the way we've got a
big echo on this audio
well let's let's keep going for a minute
I want to come back to this I have not
fully understood this yeah there are a
lot of examples in that zone okay okay
entity level functions and features okay
so this is what we were just looking at
so this here makes use of a of the
person friend
what what is this this is this is not a
property there is a profit Randall I can
try to explain there is a property is
called friend right there is just a
number like 1 2 3 and it is the primary
key of the person so each person God in
the database a column that is named
friend with the number 2 but if you
follow these you can extract but if you
get person friend you get the same so
what you're saying is if I were to do
this with just friend here instead just
get those numbers right yeah the
relation are dressing the one in this
particular case he's our syntax of
entity and entity class so you can chain
well that's in a really obscure way to
say it I might say so I mean
they are well maybe it doesn't do
obscure why to say it there they're
mostly headdress for what the database
is concerned but for the syntax in the
language they're really important yes
okay all right so let's keep going here
mate boxes about yeah the the slowness
of formatting okay all right entity
property okay so let's see if I
understand this so this is the full name
of the person
this is entry value and what I'm doing
so that's everything of typed person so
I don't need to say entity property of
full name I could just say full name
here yeah okay so that's equivalent to
just saying full name comma age okay
great
so this is person one
so I don't need to say it that way I
could just say Here Come a full name
but this is an alternative for Miss
Sarah
right absolutely right this is use when
when when you're starting doing joints
and you have conflicting names and you
need to refer exactly you know I gotta
gather yeah so this case here is what
what is the null list for entity class
but it means all of them is just that
you can just use a naked string there
what why isn't isn't that just all Tony
what are those it's an empty list of
conditions it's simply how end of no
arguments gives true
I see could you say all there as well
yes okay
all right okay so now
now things get jollier um okay so let me
just to see if I understand this so if I
would say forget all that if I would
just say entity function of height over
weight then I would be computing for
each of those people that thing and that
is happening the database yes
right and this is an alternative which
is the entity property normally this
would be the entity property on the left
so if I were to say here of just so I
understand this if I will say here of
entity
person comma three for example whatever
it is
okay cool all right now
that's happening across so each one of
these is essentially mapping across an
entry in this person
thing I don't quite understand why I
mean in in other kinds of world this
would be something like in person
compute this but the way to think about
it is like if you think about it like
entity and entity class on one hand and
he property entity function on the other
hand are like Brian ket it's like like a
dyadic form reading so that's that's
good model of thinking about it
Oh what would you say first you said
brand can what was the rock and ket Oh
brah and cat okay I was I didn't had no
idea what I didn't know how knowledge we
were dealing with here um alternatively
you can see or maybe similarly you can
see entity various an outer product of
the list of entities and the first
argument and a list of properties in the
second argument
yes I understand but what will be the
kind of pseudo linguistic version of
this like in SQL what would you say in
SQL to get this
well you can just wrap whatever function
that displays SQL to use if you wrap it
around this I'll tell you which what to
type you will see a scale okay they'll
just wrap wrap this query in a function
called entity query to ask your string
yeah for the whole thing all the whole
thing yes so it doesn't evaluate this
thing is a problem yes yes this thing is
although whole first so you see that you
have a selection of where T 2 2 3 is an
alias for the table then you have a list
of properties the computed properties at
the end its division why is it listing
all of those properties in the selector
actually it's not I mean it's not it's
not really something like we did this in
five minutes to show you just how
because we knew you were gonna ask it
but the thing that is sent to the
database is further optimized so you
wouldn't have all the lists you just
have the T two to three height divided
by two to three away it hasn't that prop
okay okay well I hope our syntax is an
improvement it becomes an improvement
when you construct more complicated
queries and in particular our syntax is
functional so it's built in the same set
of abstractions that people are used to
an orphan language well SQL syntax is
not really functional okay and we
support multiple back end so you don't
really need to know the specific of
Postgres versus my sequel to use them
right okay now what happens if you give
another function here right now we just
says that it's an invalid query that you
can't compile what is the actual wooden
you can try try putting something like
the dot product between height and
weight I think it will tell you
something that it found the simple that
it didn't
that is absolutely incomprehensible yeah
I mean something that I did yesterday
for this because before that it was like
spewing a lot of stuff okay so what we
want to say here is um something like
backtick backtick that would be area a I
cannot be
converted cannot
something like for execution in the SQL
database
you know there are all kinds of reason
why this can happen we actually
implemented a type system and if you we
we are also detecting you know if you
are sending the wrong type tool to a
function the database would complain
what we are getting this earlier and our
type system will alert us the physic you
are trying to do something in body so
not use the word compile here because
we're going to be using that a lot for
the compiler okay I think something like
this that may not be most wonderful but
go ahead but but on the other hand still
one we should realize at least among us
that what's happening is actual
compilation into a scale I'm aware
I mean it's wonderful um I'm
it's it's all good is there any
possibility of callbacks for most of us
to create functions in principle yes but
it depends on the backend and it's
probably something that is not very we
we could do it right
we could do that instead of it isn't a
callback it could be a pre call so to
speak or we can evaluate that in pieces
yes but I thought you mount something
which happens from within the query that
is already being executed on the
database well that would be nice but
what I'm saying is an alternative would
be break up that query into pieces that
can be independently run on the database
and then you know compute you know first
compute P of weight then for all those
weights compute the area and keep going
can be done the big problem is that it's
kind of hard to that automatically in a
witness performant and that you don't
know before you run the query whether
you're gonna get 1 million heights and
and at least this guarantees that
everything happens out of court here I
understand and also databases have
indexes and other means of speeding
things up and so as soon as you are on a
top level you may be out of work I
understand if you want to listen to that
we need to have like some planet that is
that is saying to you you know if I'm
going to do this entity function what is
going to happen and that should tell you
yeah this guy is happening the DB this
is happening together and so on right I
mean this is already plenty useful okay
but I mean people are going to get
people are gonna get confused well I
guess it is probably better to just fail
for the time being um well okay the
other possibility would be to say
something like
something like query includes
functionality
but see I don't think we want to spend
so much time here because because we
really wanted one inventory off all
right I'm just trying to think about how
to think about this that cannot be
executed directly in the execute and the
connected SQL database something like
that I don't know I'm we just we're just
trying to get some kind of cognitive
model for people that there is a certain
set of functionality that can be
executed and there's other stuff that
cannot be exactly and we also need to
think about the limitation because you
see this list that we are we are you
know we need to document the fact that
basically we are supporting only this
stuff would you put that in the
documentation for entity function
probably exactly okay so and obviously
this thing had no units what would
happen if we try to add units to this
you will have a database that already
contains units oh well there is a there
is one workaround which is that we can
like add an interpreter type to to age
and then we can during completion time
we can do be in it compression of the
literals but it's not going to be as
sophisticated as like for example
precision tracking might be a mess we
can work probably not for freeze for
virtue for version one we are not
planning to support I think we want to
have also some design for numeric arrays
and like a way that you know you can get
out result in columns because we in the
field we're planning to returns like
column array from the throat from the
database it may be the users console
nice that by the way um Sandra on our
live stream points out that this is
something we could perfectly well do
right that everything is to do lists
like things that don't contain slots can
be compiled
precompiled into constants fine why is
this failing just it's just block
it's okay alright okay so that will work
um by the way we had a suggestion
earlier about embedding UML graph in our
blob here what is actually really did
the reading ice-like graph kind of thing
probably doesn't it's too big for the
blog oh yeah also it hasn't been updated
to the recent changes but I've been
showing it some time ago and if you
don't remember we can return to that I
do remember yes that's an interesting
thing so that's a visualization
basically the database structure so
that's an alternative to database in
your app yeah correct yeah it can be a
property of the entities third Rob
that's an interesting idea so is it the
case that any entity store has a UML
representation no I mean any memory
entity store will not really have
relations okay because because it's
basically just flat associations so well
that's an interesting question in itself
or maybe we could support it for
in-memory store as well the relations if
it's relational yeah you need to define
that at certain property let's put that
on the shelf as something to discuss
okay
think if you're yeah if you keep going
this example they're really nicely
why is entity count I don't understand
what that is that's that's not a
standard entity value that properly is
it
it is a start to scram
okay fine okay all right okay let's keep
going here okay entity extend add a
property which is the ratio of height to
weight okay so entity extend does this
and why is it returning that is it's
it's there's a sub volleys I mean it's
like continued value in tanks you can
see the brackets on the right where we
are abstracting to properties oh I see I
see I see I see I say sorry I didn't see
that so if I just look at the entity
extend here I see that will just show me
that and this is now extracting those
properties so if I were to just see if I
actually understand what's going on so
let's say I did this I said let's say I
do
then let's say I say entity function of
Q comma
[Music]
on this is person so I can do that of a
person there I can say Q of ratio
squared
that probably worth it can you just use
multiplication
I won't scribe and ask you a light
unfortunately do not support power a
sine cosine and so on there are C
extension to that and we need to plug in
some C extension to that so I don't know
if we will manage to to add support for
it coming like square you could compile
that into absolutely yes it's an
integral but but you have to understand
that this this whole thing like there
are multiple dialects they're all
different like well if it doesn't do you
have a discovery mechanism for knowing
whether a particular function is
supported in a particular database
yeah we were actually basically
compiling this metadata by hand
okay so then if you won't see that it
isn't that it doesn't support squared
then you can take x squared and turn it
into x times X yes and if you have power
of 2.5 life okay so this is entity
extended we will be finally happy with
the name and to extend you said that you
want to turn all of these into nouns
because they don't evaluate I right but
on the other hand there is a precedence
on the language where things like select
and others which have curried forms they
also don't evaluate for with a single
argument when I correct that this
doesn't have a none curried form oh yeah
one could argue that entity value is the
courage Burma from it well yeah I mean
so entity extension is also not right
because entity extended or extended
entity well it's not one entity it's
more of like the class so but I mean I
think you should first get the full
picture and then and then we can play
the name game because because for some
things like sort it's really weird
you
you
you
hydrogate okay so entity aggregate
conveniently a noun so this is the
entity aggregate of now does this work
you can execute it no no no I'm asking
for built-in entities the notion of an
entity aggregate would also be a
possible thing and I'm am I right yes I
implemented all those functions for
entity stores in memory and alpha so in
principle you should be able to use them
for anything so let's try entity
aggregate element so now what does this
say so now I want to make you make a
rule then first you name it
yeah I understand so let's say I want to
say
what is this doing this is making its
making a proper shelter on time
and giving it a name so in this case
entity function has different semantics
then then then in the property because
it's like working on the groups well no
here it's going to be lets say mean of
queue of density right yeah yeah and
then you see this drives me crazy it
does me crazy that this doesn't evaluate
well it's not I mean yeah so now what do
I do here because this is a thousand
years average but why is that the right
thing what what what good does this do
me it's super good because you can you
you can actually chain these things that
you can treat them symbolically it's but
what is it what is it I don't understand
what it is yeah this is the thing you
wanted a grenade works like a class it's
like an implicit class of some sort and
and you can chain them you Nestor I
don't stop what is this explain to me
what this entity I agree with is in this
case okay basically returns an entity
class but then it depends whether or not
you have a third argument returns as the
class in this case what entity class is
it returning it's an entity class that
doesn't currently have a type because
it's like the elements together in the
form do remember Steven the discussion
about runtime types we had some time yes
yes but but just explain to me what this
means in the case that I just entered
okay the case is that you just entered
this means it's it's you will have an
entity type that contains a single
entity and that entity is all the
elements and they will have only one
property that's the average density okay
but so this this is putting a constant
across lots of entities in an entity of
an entity class is that right
just putting some kind of constant the
same value no no no if you look at this
there's only one value in it so there is
only one it's only one Anthony wise
Weiss not a single turret no no he can't
it can be it like without the list think
of this as an average entity that
contains the mean only single property
that is a mean density of all entities
in this original type then you know what
I think this should be I'm sorry I think
this should be called I think this one
should be aggregated I think the other
one should be Connie this one here
should be called extended entity it's
it's not an entity it's not a class
it's NC class because you see it returns
list all these return lists so algebra
cleaner classes and also for this for
the aggregate there is a third argument
which are when you divide things into
groups and then it becomes not a single
entity but a bunch of them each one over
the group that you summed over so also
for aggregate it's not always a single
entity only if you have only two
arguments if you have third argument
then it becomes entity class I don't
know but this would be much clearer to
me if it said aggregated entity then I
know that I formed an aggregated entity
which I can then pick up as a as a thing
and similarly here I formed an extended
entity which I can pick up as a thing am
I making sense except for extend you
definitely know that in all cases it
will be generally energy class so call
it extended entity will just not be
correct yeah
okay I mean that's not the worst name in
the world
aggregated entity costs because at least
it says what it is I claim all right but
let's go down here
is keep the one mean wait by sex is oh
it's my basics
aggregate identity of type person where
this is
this is the property that you compute
from those groups over which you
aggregate yes I understand
and those are the groups with Uruguay
the arguments in this order because we
decided before we had entity aggregate
by an entity I will gate and now we
decided that the third argument could be
optional and so let's just I'm not sure
it's the right place I'm not sure it
shouldn't be optional in the second
argue in the second position okay let me
just have a quick scan through here
because we're running out of time I did
and I liked correct we're running out of
time yeah we have Samians okay so let's
take a look here oh my gosh by the
amount of things we still have to
discuss it might be wiser to have a
continuation where we could explain this
to you in proper give it justice I think
you're understating we can't possibly
cover this in four minutes
no yeah we we need like three hours per
week yes yes so let's let's block out
what we need to do okay so I think
there's some naming issues
I think there is some graphic design
issues that we were encountering at the
beginning um
let me see if I can read the fine fails
type-checking
can we start doing like documentation
for Ltd aggregate like all those things
that don't really need the database back
they already working memory yeah but if
we haven't decided on name well okay
that's why I think we okay so let's just
look at sure this is why I'm suggesting
we can start doing you know design good
let me just look at the one like this
okay I'm just gonna evaluate this this
is like looking at the end of the book
first okay let's see if I understand
what this is saying entity join across
okay
humm so this is a self join
person-to-person and you're joining on
the condition that the age of the person
is the same but the name is different
right okay so there's two things in the
entity function the person and their
twin okay it's really an arbitrary
condition you okay so if I just take the
entity join across oops why is that okay
god this drives me crazy that this does
nothing unless that name but Stevens the
Hyundai does nothing he's actually all
the power of this well I I'm not
complaining about the fact that it does
nothing okay I'm not complaining I think
that's great I just can't stand the name
okay right I can't stand that the name
suggests that you know I mean like for
example okay
suggesting this name but if this was
called entity join across function it
will be happier
yeah I understand what you're saying
it's just super confusing to see
something which looks like it's an
action and it isn't an action yeah I
mean maybe there's another modifier that
[Music]
that can go with it that represents this
fact that it is a UH okay so let's just
read this thing okay so
yeah okay fine this is nice
I mean I I think that the stuff with
relations it's really a lot more
intuitive than joins and really really
powerful you scroll up a little bit if
you want to see something that like all
these questions like who is the enemy of
the enemy ok so let's take a look at
this and to the extent I can't stand the
name but let's say extended entity let
me just put that name in there for the
sake of me understanding what's going on
its extended entity which is a person
with the extended feature that they have
a total in them right and the total
takes this thing and it is applying this
thing here yeah so it's basically
following the relation transaction tool
which then returns an entity class and
getting out all the amounts but then at
this point you cannot have notate unless
you you flatten it out so you need to
total is it you know again sorry SQL for
this what's that
maybe they actually asked you out for
this it's pretty neat okay the function
can call it equarico ask your strings
you should see that there is a sub query
now in it yeah so this stuff is like
becomes you really complicated to reason
about in SQL please color code SQL in
some way I have this functionality in
utilities but it's not available in the
build
so which functionality the color coding
of SQL okay so we use it internally -
exactly for the same purpose but it's
not included in the main project we
might in principle people normally don't
I mean if we decide that we want to do
some nice SQL nobody cares about the SQL
that's the whole point of what
building yeah so that's why this give
people something which is a string that
they can actually run in a database then
suddenly which is annotated with colors
but they have to throw away the
annotations before he can go out okay
well I can't read this so there's no
point in I won't be impressed it's just
a bunch of I mean I have to say that we
get to the point where I mean this one
is still pretty tame but if you start
following two three relations then you
get a bunch of sub queries which will
probably optimize away at some point
bits are not very efficient it's like
something that write by hand in SQL is
like crazy and in entities as soon as
you get a handle it hang of it yeah the
next example we're doing matrix
multiplication sorry vector
multiplication yeah sorry we are doing
the mean of the ID versus the hate and
if you and if you see like person
transaction to person from height that
is an array of
what was the thing called again entity
query why is this
it looks looks like it is something
wrong because the annulation is not
there this is this is just select lever
like if you can see it but try try
putting just the entity extending I said
on that oh it won't work without any
value yeah
I won't work yeah then there is
something yeah there's something I need
to yeah this is an experimental feature
which I just did today so sorry if it
doesn't work always but you shouldn't be
able to see like two nested selecting
all right is there anything okay okay as
we try and get this renaming done okay
so you guys can think about it okay I'm
recommending extended entity class
aggregated entity class sword okay then
there is one last nagging thing it's
that the original entity class doesn't
nest with all this stuff what do you
mean that you can't wrap and the class
around any of these trees inst in place
when to select just won't work I mean it
can be made to work but Tony claims that
it's the wrong name for it
for what for for using the end like you
can instead of using and he select
around an entity aggregates you can use
an entity class which is shorter like
Lisa T with the implicit conditions
that's in case if you don't want to
write any function they'll have some
condition that it's simple enough to be
expressed in this concise form that
entity class allows you to yes
so what Tony so my thinking was that
entity class wasn't designed with that
in mind so it has basically two purposes
one to represent some entities and the
second is how do you represent it by a
filter so what I would be more happiness
is introducing entity filter and using
dead to wrap things or
okay we'll have to talk about that um
okay but I'm strongly encouraging the
use of these noun forms okay we can we
can come up with I don't know what the
Joyner cross noun form should be
that's the other one that has to be done
right all you can then say join the
energy class okay yeah but it's joins in
the wrong direction that's the problem
the problem is that if you join 20
classes you would think that they are
joined row wise instead join a cross is
a join column wise
well I mean no this is too grotesque
that is absolutely grotesque
all right so still problems to be solved
here
okay so again there's gonna be about a
half hour I think which is going to be
devoted to the graphic design stuff then
I think this naming thing is going to
take I think that's gonna take another
half hour and then there's more stuff to
go over
but there's looking for a nice guys so
it's in the old what happens in the
cloud by the way did we decide that this
is we decided yeah so far this is Java
so it can be whitelisted okay all right
so that then then if you point it at so
for example from the cloud if we opened
up the firewall we could look at some
internal database perfectly well correct
yeah great okay all right I gotta go do
something else um here actually for
those who are following our live streams
of the day we have unsupervised machine
learning coming up in half an hour so
stay tuned I've got to work on something
different for 30 minutes here um all
right and this is really nice Frank
Charlie this is great and and apart from
that startup it's looking like it's it's
working pretty nicely yeah I'll be
looking into this startup time just
pretty much starting tomorrow osteon
okay great all right let's try to meet
behind a few days so that we haven't
lost context here if possible sure okay
and by the way that the people in the
roadmap meeting did not really know
about this project are you aware of that
dates but just okay well because I
repainted that to make sure that they
were aware that this project was coming
okay all right good stuff thanks a lot
see you soon thank you